in recent weeks shopping at this beijing
fresh food market has become more
expensive
the price has gone up we can't afford it
we had to buy some vegetables from the
dealers on the street the prices of
common vegetables such as cucumbers
spinach and broccoli have doubled
some have become more expensive than
pork the staple meat in china so when on
monday the chinese government issued a
notice advising households to stockpile
daily necessities it sparked panic and
heated discussion online
some posted about rushing to buy
essential goods
others speculated that increasing
tensions with taiwan were the cause
but analysts say the announcement has
been misinterpreted the reason that they
put that notice out was basically
you know routine
winter season preparedness for making
sure that there's a good supply of fruit
and vegetables on the market and normal
daily goods and that some of the reason
that language was in there was due to
you know the the potential sort of
ongoing risk of covert lockdowns
the pandemic has led to a renewed focus
on china's food security
regional lockdowns have disrupted food
supplies to affected areas
and there have been other challenges
last month crops in china's northeast a
major food growing region were destroyed
by unusually heavy rains
a nationwide power shortage has pushed
up the cost of operating greenhouses and
a shortage of diesel fuel has delayed
cross-country deliveries
experts say china's emergency food
reserves and mechanisms are generally in
good shape but while there isn't a
shortage price hikes and supply
disruptions have been hurting those who
can least afford it those in china's
lowest income bracket living in smaller
cities and rural areas
officials have moved to stabilize
vegetable prices
local governments will be instructed to
ensure market supply and price stability
for daily necessities in the coming
winter and next spring
we will establish and improve the
relevant safeguard and supply mechanisms
and release government reserves at their
profit time beijing has also issued an
action plan to reduce food waste in the
restaurant and catering industries
meanwhile shoppers are hoping that
skyrocketing prices will soon return to
normal katrina you al jazeera beijing